Oh pee all over me hello everybody my
name is markiplier welcome back to Super
Mario maker the challenge is still on
every time I curse damn and such I will
donate money to Chile
well why did I even bother what was the
point of that why did I even decide to
do oh that's helpful
oh so this is gonna be about precision
is it I am NOT a precise person in fact
the last time that I was fudge poop poop
lots of poop bunch of slime rancher bull
I didn't even need them why do they even
try that's a question I ask myself every
morning why did I even track did I even
try why even bother if I know that all
its going to end in failure that's bull
honky that's [ __ ]
I kind of want to say it so I'm willing
to pay the toll it's bull Taizo because
it's always worth trying is there
something here oh okay well that's good
oh I can go right under it oh god damn
it
ah Fraggle nuts I'm gonna die cuz I
don't have my spring dingleberry Oh fart
my knuckles I don't even know what I'm
saying anymore ah flabber duke what is
this what is this what what I don't
understand I can't comprehend there's
gonna be a [ __ ] and a half
ah go with me young buddy be a pal
give me dem blocks I hate precision I
like to be a very imprecise person in my
life I like to be nothing but absolute
carnage for the entirety of everything
that I do okay so the trick here is to
wait longer to press this I didn't even
kick that long I just I accidently can
you oh god I just it just I I down
dropped it it's just like now didn't do
it good enough do it good enough that's
the story of my life right there I
didn't do it okay so this time I'm gonna
plan this a little better gonna get this
and be ready for it
here that's good enough I'm scared but I
bet I toss this up here yes what that
did a whole lot of nothing for me oh god
I need to wait longer yeah I don't know
if there was something that was supposed
to be happening there but it didn't work
out no matter what it was God is going
so badly for me I hope you all are
keeping count at home because Matt you
know he's a young and he doesn't quite
know his numbers and such so I don't
think he can count that high now you
better not be added
just because I'm insulting you because
that's rather douchey no oh God is that
enough then even if I don't know what
this is this dude
oh no I needed that but I needed to hear
I bet that looks important but oh no I
need the coop is still there so I need
the coop as my constant companion
because he is compadre in this scenario
and he's helping me how did I not get
that you might ask because I'm trying to
both say things for you guys and also at
the same time I'm really trying to ah no
no nope nope nope got grab it there we
go
that did it okay so now I gotta send
this up oh oh God
I don't know how that happened that is
no okay I probably needed that to get
the rest okay so now that I got this
great new God blast my ass Oh Frick damn
it
god damn it stop doing that pissant
yes pissant the most terrible of that's
Oh No maybe get it down get down get
down
boink do the thing ya do this now do
this oh look at this all the time the
world baby
Oh more time yeah yeah yeah
who the man unmanned atom an atom an
okay place this guy right no this time
not gonna do surround I'm not gonna go
to the other side when they blow this
well look at you okay place run blam
winner chicken dinner go over here gimme
whoa who was that supposed to come out
that quickly and I'm gonna get this
perfectly perfectly positioned so the
vet gets exactly the effect this high
desire couple if now I'm gonna stand
here because it's gonna do it there and
then I'm gonna stand here because it's
gonna do it it's there now I'm gonna get
you
twink and then peel then I'm gonna pee
yes
then I'm gonna stop you
that is balls those count I don't know
is balls of curse pulses in the curse
word I can say balls all I want balls
balls balls balls balls balls poopie
poopie balls poopie balls up the button
poopie balls up my but it's not curse
words doesn't count
not it's not bad it wouldn't it wouldn't
be censored on TV probably I don't know
maybe poopie balls up my butt might be
censored but not on YouTube that's all
that matters
come on over here buddy turtle friend
friend who is turtle it's better be
enough time let's go let's go let's go
pee all over me pee pee pee in my face
and my hair and my eyes and my balls pee
on my balls in my hair and my eyes on my
face in my licks lips pee on my lips my
liquors baby talking about the p-block
not literally that would be grossly
inappropriate and would probably be
tantamount to paying money to charity
but that's not the case cuz that's not
it's not how it be because you have a
dirty huh chim chiminey chim chiminey
chim - druh
why why would you why would you not why
would you not do it why would you not
why would you ha ha maybe if I open my
super wide I'll be able to see
everything that's coming up to screw me
over would look at the way that others
that was delightful I wonder if anyone
else out there saw it how much I came
close to being blown around it was very
close Matt do an instant replay of that
one there we go that's the stuff yeah
yeah buddy
yeah point oh good for me now I'll be
able to blaze through this with new
problem no oh no really really really
yeah that is it yeah the checkpoint to
make sure you don't have extra oh hey oh
god what is this no I don't want to what
I don't want to do this this seems
horrible I need to pee block that's not
a P block oh god oh gosh I don't know
what you want from me did I need a bomb
for that or something oh god why no no I
refused I did your game I played enough
I did enough dammit eternal death
eternal death eternal death sure no duh
it's right there the end so what do I
need to do I didn't see a bomb
maybe if I get it from down here now
that's not no no no you will die that's
what I needed I'm pretty sure I probably
need to get both from the small one not
the big one and then grab the small one
is that pulling out Seymour boink boink
oh that's douchey okay got both got both
okay now yes I knew it oh yes I knew it
oh God
oh my gosh yay okay all the dingus
tangles in the world
little close there buddy little close
there friend oh here we go this is Devon
this is Devon area wink wink
boink
yeah I didn't give up I didn't give up
for once in my life I didn't give up I
didn't give up I didn't give up I didn't
give up I didn't give up okay
so that's enough Mario maker for now
thank you everybody so much for watching
Matt what was the final tally on the
cursing wow that's a number then we'll
be donating that to charity so thank you
everybody so much for watching hope you
enjoyed this and I don't know how much
more Mario maker I'm gonna play but if
you guys wanted I'll play some more but
probably I'm gonna move on to other
games pretty soon so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video